i
[Música]
me gustan
muy bien la noche es una conferencia aún
explique más cuántas llevan 11
dos más ya mi casa guys qué placer es
para mí o bien muchas gracias no muchas
por las palabras para mí es un honor
presentarme ante ustedes serán el xhosa
comediante cuando ya sabe que tengo por
ahí de ojo de buen cubero 15 kg gracias
ojalá 15 la mía cuantos más que tengo
25 26 y hacen arrugas del cuello cuando
me agacho no tengo 26 añitos 20 añitos
viviendo de muchas cosas de la comedia
llevo siete años viviendo de la comedia
antes de empezar mucha gente no me
conoce porque no soy mijares entonces
tampoco gozo donde estas bellas mieles
de la fama convención mijares me
presento rápido soy daniel el comediante
mi historia estaba un poco rara no
porque es un poco distinta a la
idealización de la historia de muchas
familias por ejemplo yo tuve desgracia
una foto primero con mi mamá
está mejor a los siete años deja de su
[ __ ] madre
la caliza no pero el niño ahí estaba el
festival del día de las madres mamá
música y tu [ __ ]
y el tema es que yo crecí sin mamá pero
ahí les va mi abuela materna para
platicar nazco 19 de noviembre del 93
una vez que nazca mi papá y mi mamá se
van a vivir junto a la casa de mi abuela
materna no mi abuela materna a la cual
yo llamo mamá way o hitler es cualquiera
de las dos mamás o más no por aquello
porque la quiero mucho me voy con mi
mamá web y en los siete años normalmente
hoy tengo pondrás ya no me gustó no mi
papá se quedó viviendo con sus suegros o
sea mi papá cómodo porque no pagaba ni
renta ni agua lee tengo un hijo señora
también normalmente se queda conmigo
hasta primero de secundaria porque por
quien primero secundaria mi papá dijo
sabes que estoy harto de que no podamos
escoger nuestras cortinas nos vamos a
independizar no es que pasó nos
independizamos que fue nos fuimos
es broma nos fuimos escribieron no era
yo era adam
nos fuimos a vivir a otro lado mi papá
me llevo de la casa de mis abuelos y nos
llevó a una colonia que se llama linda
vista en la ciudad de mexico
según él
la vista es una colonia tan mala como
como las demás pero no nos fuimos a una
corona cerca de lindavista la industrial
donde estaban las fábricas donde matan
pues no
y estuvo horrible porque mi papá no dijo
nada más de aquí yo me fui con él no
deje a mi abuela y mis abuelos son ex
petroleros entonces tenían dinero que
pasaba con esas mis abuelos no me
dejaban salir de ninguna manera solo ni
nada que pasó a mi papá dejamos
independizarnos vivió un chingo de cosas
no cambian de tener una escuela privada
a una escuela pública aprende a pelearme
aprender a la amia pero al final arman
potazos no sea feroz feos de esos que ya
ellos a peleas con un chilla risa
con esto estamos jugando tranquilos güey
el tema es que después de ahí me empecé
a dar cuenta que había cosas que yo no
entendía no empecé a valorar la vida les
digo esto que tengo un amigo que se
llamaba óscar que desgraciadamente lo
matan al lado de mí que estaba en la
secundaria y jordanos por chela
obviamente está en secundaria no
teníamos de manera de conseguir chela
chocará way ahora llevábamos y justo
cuando vamos a vernos huesca una pistola
ahora sí ya valió [ __ ]
y yo puse
me pregunta vienes con el ios y cartucho
lo cortan vienes con él si no saben lo
difícil que es ver eso
sí sí sí sí saben no y qué pasa ahí
aprendes muchas cosas pude haber sido yo
un pedo llegó la policía de meterme en
la gana policía porque tuve estos 70 y
llegó su mamá pues me enteré que había
pasado cosas que él tenía pedos de
drogas y la china la para esto yo no he
visto a mi mamá desde que fue eso en esa
época y papá se fue mejor solo viviendo
solo yo por ahí de los 15 y 16 años como
pagaba
mis cosas viviendo solo es jugar fútbol
y bajar chile me la pelan no entonces
pelaban y ahorita ya me probé hace una
semana y ya no me paro tan rápido como
antes pero yo voy a apostar a las
canchas de fútbol rápido pues dinero
para ver si podía sacar lana con eso no
y qué pasa con eso que yo entendí que
tenía que luchar por lo que yo quería
de repente un año nuevo no quiero estar
solo voy con mi familia materna llega mi
abuela y me dice hola te acuerdas de
ella y mi mamá llega de visita cosas de
mí y yo
y mejor hijo de tu [ __ ] madre
y regresa y mamá porque no la odio pero
que no pelee con ella porque es más
importante tener una convivencia
familiar sana que estar haciendo caja
estoy enojado contigo yo no te voy a
hablar no porque hay dañaba toda mi
familia qué pasa después empiezo a
trabajar de becario veo que hay una
concepción estando yo había visto comida
desde chavito cuando veo que estando
obligó a mi familia hoy al quiero hacer
estando y todos me dijeron si te
apoyamos y yo hay nuevo me meto un curso
me inscribo y que pasa una vez que me
inscribo digo oiga no sé cuando el apoyo
y hay que pagar rayista la época del
apoyo se dice no te vamos a apoyar ellos
no te pases y viene
ya la traigo adentro pues a la deuda
pues no estamos familia no te vamos a
apoyar
y oscar a málaga
y tomé el curso estando para escondidas
de mi familia yo me iba de la prepa
cruzaba la ciudad para andar estando
pide aprender a hacer esto qué pasa con
eso empiezo a la comedia y me doy cuenta
que la comedia es mucho más de lo que
muchas personas creen no solo es subirse
sin chistes o groserías la importancia
de la comedia es entender que es una
catarsis de un pensamiento muy sencillo
ok premisa remate todo lo que estamos
aquí desde el chavo de lentes que se
parece a john mayer hasta que está ya
que está guapísimo todos y todas se
pueden hacer chistes como muy fácil
premisas y remates pero mira es una idea
el remate es la descontextualización o
la jiribilla que yo le llamo no cómo voy
a hacer eso muy sencillo piensas en un
personaje darth vader pone en un
universo que no es el del y existoso
donde la obesidad del chavo del ocho'
hay haciendo eso y hay hay comedia me
doy cuenta que según profesional y toma
el curso cuando toma esa edición
adal ramones
ahí estoy yo vean un chavo haciendo
comedia pero lo que realmente se habrán
escuchado engañando a su mamá voy
diciéndole que está en una casa haciendo
un trabajo y no cierto
ese es un chavo mentiroso
luego yo no entiendo qué pasaba no
empezó a crecer toda la comedia me
empecé a ir muy chido las adiós empiezo
a trabajar porque leo muchos libros se
come bien hago un link de la comedia y
me distraigo que me distrae el amor de
mi familia como el amor de mi familia mi
familia no quiere que siguiera esto por
amor pero yo no entendía eso yo lo veía
como un coraje porque mi familia me
decía como estos son palabras textuales
de mi abuela como crees que tú vas a
hacer comediante danielle
y qué pasó que mi abuela no gira porque
me amaba tanto que le daba a mí de
exponerse y exponerme a un mundo que yo
no conocía me distrajo eso me distrajo
el dinero qué pasa cuando tienes el
dinero no sabes qué hacer y esto solo su
persona me dijo un compadre ahí les va
puede ayudar plis para ponerle el ideal
de este todas cosas en qué momento te
diste cuenta que perdiste tiempo porque
es ahorita los a los lópez no tienes
clarísimo y gracias o sea por igual el
nombre de todos porque ya tienes chance
de decir nuestra 4ta cosas porque y
media gente que escucha esto que está en
la vida que no se dado cuenta que está
distraída fíjate que donde más pierde
uno tiempo es es muy difícil
ejemplificar pero si te lo trató de
generalizar donde más pierdes tiempo es
donde busca es el dinero
ok cada vez que hay algo que tiene
dinero inmerso que te tienta por dinero
ahí estará la pérdida de tiempo y dices
hoy te acaban de ofrecer que si haces
como dije hace rato una gira de
a todos los oxxos del país y durante
seis meses vas a estar y te pagan muy
bien
claro porque prioriza el dinero en lugar
de tu uso exacto se nos va a decir que
va a dejar la gira nada pero me pagan
muy bien ahí estás perdiendo un friego
de tiempo a cambio de dinero que se da
cuando te des cuenta y dices pues no
compre un carro
no sé mejor en mi departamento o lo que
sea pero no te hace avance en touche en
tu chamba y te quedas y al paso del
tiempo de repente volteo para atrás y
digo way a la época que más perdí tiempo
es cuando me sentí que estaba yo más
ocupado cuando más pierdes tiempo es
cuando sientes que estás más ocupados
cuando escaló single i ching gray no
gano dinero pussy [ __ ] estás
chingando leen cosas que no te suman
cuál es tu sueño cuál es tu [ __ ] sueño
mi papá quería ser futbolista y no pudo
porque por [ __ ]
porque era muy bueno oyeron muy buen
wake fútbol pero no puedo cantando tenía
otras necesidades como que es pagar para
la casa pues paga para la casa pero
juega fútbol te va a costar más trabajo
vas a sudar y te vas a partir la madre
pero de eso se trata si no serías parte
del montón ahora que otra cosa te
distrae y realizar vidas ajenas por
ejemplo estamos en una época en la que
todo el mundo ve redes sociales y todo
el mundo está aquí han sepa lo que es
falso ven a juanpa zurita veintitantos
años exitoso viaje dinero mujeres a xiii
todos los chavitos tal vez no lo sepan o
tal vez sí pero los chavos aspiran a eso
y sobre cuello tengo la edad desde
juanpa y no tengo dinero porque cada
quien a su tiempo el éxito es su
objetivo más o menos que me enseñó esto
otro amigos vamos a ver esto prisa
esto no es del todo el de llave
tal vez es hoy en hollywood no pensaste
en llegar a llegar a la silla de johnny
cash fíjate que no amigo porque no mas q
bien el inglés o sea no no hablo un
inglés como en su momento podríamos
decir que lo habla marco antonio régil o
marca de baile
me mandó un beso no me voy a ir solo a
buscar un triunfo tal yo quiero estar en
méxico cerca de mis hijos porque las
mieles del éxito ya las provee aparte de
esto ya proveyó eso en mi triunfo son
mis estudios me encaminados bien amigos
claro y yo termino con esta frase que me
dijo empapado un día mejor estábamos en
la calle hace un calor dónde canícula de
junio-julio en monterrey y de repente
pasó el paletero esto es real amigos
incluso el paletero iba gritando paletas
de humo porque el monito era el elefante
de humo en el carrito de paletas para el
consumo
y todo lo que yo salí a comprar paleta
de que sacas y entonces estaba amigo la
de limón la de la de novela de las las
paletas del hecho de agua la tata tata y
mi papá me dijo amigo yo teniendo creo
que habré tenido ocho años y me dijo mi
padre tú crees que sea feliz
el señor
y yo lo veía amigo él el hombre tenía la
piel curtida por el sol con chanclas ya
un señor de sus cuya piel está pegada a
la cara al hueso de flaco ya de edad
ahora ha tenido yo creo habrá tenido al
como 65 años empujando ese carrito de
paletas y yo le dije no se dopa llegó
con el sol y todo cuando le han de pagar
y dijo quédate debiendo yo ya con mi
paleta en la mano fuera del grupo de
niños que estaban metidos en el coche en
el carrito de paletas viendo la escena
de yo viendo la escena desde acá amigos
la cara del señor era de alegría total
de sacaba sacaba estoy viendo y también
lo estoy viendo se acaba la palencia de
de piña para la niña fresa para la niña
cada tamarindo para saber quién quién
quien me dio los 10 centavos quien
aunque no se está enclavado en la caja
jojojo el cuate
tocando las campanitas del carrito
y yo dije papá yo creo que sí de
justicia es feliz dijo tener éxito no es
tener el mejor coche ni el cheque con
más ceros ni la casa más grande ni tener
algún tipo de una esposa bonita guapa o
eso no es el éxito el éxito es ser feliz
con lo que hagas y me dijo mi padre yo
no quiero un título en la pared
yo no quiero que te reciba sigas papá
aquí está mi título de doctor a mí no me
importa si eres doctor o lo que sea o
paletero yo nomás te pido que seas feliz
que me viene a decir algo va
[Aplausos]
mucha gente ve a nadal y me ha dicho
igual que vale verdad
no sólo tiene que ver no es lo que
decimos es cierto no
siguiente dice eso porque realizaba a
dallas haciendo cosas muy grandes como
como el señor que lleva una generación
de la mano de la comedia como ahorita
está conduciendo la academia porque será
tu sueño no el de él él quería ser papá
y se chingó y no está mal no idealicemos
vidas ajenas
ese es un error cabrón porque de ahí
nace la frustración hacia nuestros
propios sueños y luego crees que un
sueño es algo inalcanzable cuando un
chavito que su abuela la mujer que lo
crió le dijo tú no puede ser comentó que
ésta es un hábitat si se puede y vivo de
esto desde hace siete años cabrón te lo
juro por mi madre que me dijo que si se
puede
ahora les va el [ __ ]
yo trabajar me doy cuenta que hay cosas
que me distraen pero hay cosas que yo
quiero yo en él uno de mis anhelos más
grandes es el comediante reconocido por
excelencia no a nivel mexicano no a
nivel mundial un comediante que va a
presentar los oscar y va a tener su late
night en eeuu como siendo mexicano
impresionantemente cagado como no puede
hacer para hacer eso trabajando
trabajando voy a llegar no sé igual me
muero antes vi vale [ __ ] todo
pero igual y sí y como a lugares o
trabajando
ahora llevan muchas pláticas muchas
conferencias diciendo que todo está bien
todo está mal todos podemos todos no
podemos chavos
de compás
déjense de [ __ ]
dejes de andar buscando a es que ahora
si el lunes bueno nada ahorita salen
bueno ahorita no hoy se pelan hoy es
noche de empezar y ya pero mañana mañana
así porque después de eso me puse a
pensar oye y yo quiero ser feliz o que
yo sea exitoso que quiero si estoy loco
ya no entiendo nada y lo único que
podría pensar es la primera foto que les
enseñé el chavito con su mamá ya saben
dije ese güey que y hoy todo mi esfuerzo
está aquí
sí no
ahí
un segundo especial faltan muchos yo
pero yo siempre me he imaginado que
alguien por aquí alguien por aquí es de
ese güey
ss viviendo
que no estaba esa mamá que él solito se
puso esa [ __ ] toalla
para pedir un favor
me voy a mañana para tengan sobriedad en
su cuerpo
creo que vayan a su casa oa su iphone o
ipad y saquen
una foto de ustedes de niños
viviana ese wey a ustedes mismos de
niños a esa misma edad
y le pregunten a los ojos oye
como ves
creen que ese niño les va a contestar yo
quiero ser como tú como ser grande
sino que chicos están esperando
porque mucha risa muchos jajaja de y si
vamos a cambiar planeta hay que ayudar
si ustedes
los niños no son el futuro son el [ __ ]
presente del país y no sólo los niños
porque ellos son los del futuro
yo ya me voy no ustedes que verán yo ya
estoy grande y luego menos tiempo qué
estás haciendo
mucha gente demerita la comida estando
por el uso de groserías lo cual me
parece chistoso porque no tengo tiempo
de explicar a la gente lo que implica el
ser estando es muy complejo es muy
complejo pero que me gusta que piense en
eso proceso que está haciendo bien mi
trabajo
ustedes señores no tiene ni idea la
oportunidad que tienen cada día que se
despierte mi amigo que lo mataron en
frente de mi ya no pueden
ustedes sí cuál es su punto pretexto de
este grande auto de oportunidades está
bien difícil todos tienes historia a mí
me tocó digo que no me dejó otro día y
mi papá se divorciaron a es que yo estoy
gordo
sin ofender
entonces me queda exactamente 15
segundos para decirles yo los quiero
mucho a todos ustedes los admiro con sus
profesiones los quiero y los admiro pero
si nada más se van a quedar ahí diciendo
cosas alargando que se pueden no poner
un ejemplo de que se puede y enseñar a
las generaciones de chiquitos medianos y
gamesa que sí se puede meta de mucho
corazón del alma chinguen a su madre
hasta luego
[Aplausos]